china had this brilliant grand strategy
which was
sure america is hostile
because america is hegemonic america
wants to control the world america will
never let china rise america will do
everything it can to hold china down
so we're going to have hostility from
america
we don't want to decouple
because we need that high-end technology
transfer
either we buy it or we steal it because
america and the rest of the west has all
the technology that we need
we have some of it domestically
more than before by a lot but we're
still dependent so we can't decouple
so we'll have the hostility but there'll
be a line we don't cross just so that we
don't lose the technology transfer
till made in china 2035
is accomplished and we're
self-sufficient
uh domestically and ai and every other
area that's critical
but hostility from america but we have
an ace in the hole
our race in the hole is europe
europe hates conflict
they're all about trade
it doesn't matter how evil you are they
love to trade because
van del del
change through trade they have this
illusion that you're going to become a
better country if they trade with you
and you won't have conflict war and
hostilities if you trade
and so we have this european ace in the
hall
we're hostile with the americans we're
still buying or stealing their
technology
and and better than that even the
europeans are not hostile to us at all
they love to trade with us and they want
to trade more and they're our biggest
trading partner already
and lo and behold xi jinping sides with
vladimir putin
in the aggression in ukraine
he doesn't
side with him providing military
equipment he doesn't provide technology
transfer
but he provides public support and
massive pro-russian propaganda to the
whole chinese population
and the europeans say wait a minute
this is an invasion of a sovereign
country in europe what do you mean
you're not condemning vladimir putin's
invasion
and so that wedge that the chinese had
that was the basis of their grand
strategy that wedge between the u.s and
europe when it came to china policy that
wedge is gone now xi jinping destroyed
it
and the europeans and the americans are
coming close together
on ukraine and russia policy for sure
but also more and more on china policy
and so that was a pretty big sacrifice
for the chinese leader to make and what
did he get in return
he gets hydrocarbons from russia at
reduced prices
and the chinese get hydrocarbons from a
lot of countries
they have a completely diverse
supply chain for their energy so what do
you think xi jinping is thinking now was
it was it a mistake or i'd like to know
alex i'd like you to be able to sit down
with him across from this table here on
your podcast and pose that same question
to him because we have no idea there's a
language barrier that's fascinating by
the way you as a scholar of stalin
do you think we'll ever break through
the language barrier to china not ever i
apologize in in the next few years
because there is a gigantic
cultural and language barrier between
the west and the china is a great
civilization china predates the united
states
by millennia
china's accomplishments are breathtaking
but china is also led
by let's be honest a communist party
monopoly
which engages in a lot of criminal
behavior lex
tibet
is ukraine
xinjiang
is ukraine
hong kong
is ukraine
let alone support for putin ukraine this
is before we've even discussed taiwan
and so now the europeans are coming to
see this and the americans are coming to
understand this
that
maybe trading with a regime like that
morally politically criminally
tibet xinjiang hong kong
how is that different from what putin is
doing in ukraine i'd be hard-pressed to
differentiate that ultimately even
though the analogies are not exact
and so the chinese
it's like that guy leona
the author of lee heletia
the the great um
memoir
of the late soviet period the end of the
soviet union
you know that they they spend all this
time and all these resources blackening
our image but we supply them with
endless material to blacken our image
that's where xi jinping's regime is
right now alex
and so they have a big dilemma on their
side
it's a western world
and they've united the western world
and and re-awoken
the western world
to
the fact that china
is a threat
to the values
the institutions and values of the west
and that trade is not transforming china
quite the opposite
we'll see if this endures
maybe it doesn't endure maybe it's a
fleeting moment maybe this is not an
inflection point
maybe the war in ukraine ends more
quickly than than we think and
maybe like you said the chinese and the
indians and the rest of them the leaders
there they get their wish that it ends
and
the world moves on
and forgets or
says let's try again to to resume
our mutual understanding our mutually
beneficial trade and everything else
maybe it's a passing phase we can't
exclude that i'm very poor at predicting
the future
but the moment is not a good one for the
chinese regime
let alone the fact that he's trying
to impose
an unprecedented in the modern era third
term
for himself as president in the fall at
the next party congress
becoming president for life
de facto
a mao like figure
and he's now got to do that
with in this environment
where he has damaged chinese grand
strategy
and damaged the reputation of china and
its relationships across the world
maybe not permanently but significantly
in addition to the problems they have at
home demography
as you know a middle income trap
and then the regulatory
insanity of chinese communist rule that
we've seen with the tech companies that
you know well where they've destroyed
all of that value
with the blow up of their property
sector
because it was a massive bubble
and that's still playing out
and this time it's the same
meaning this time it's not different
when it comes to a property blowout it
has enormous effects
on middle-class balance sheets and their
ability to
to be to remain consumers and drive the
economy which is the model that they
have to so he's got a litany of
challenges
independent even
of the fact that he sided
with his pal
vladimir putin and their bromance is
costing china very very significantly
you